die korona proteste in deutschland
bundesweit sind menschen seit wochen auf
den straßen unterwegs die sogenannten
spaziergänger die mittlerweile zu
tausenden gegen die korona politik und
eine mögliche impfpflicht demonstrieren
ein mann in karlsruhe nutzte bei einer
dieser kundgebungen aber die grund
sicher stunde er bekommt das mikrofon in
die hand und informiert die korona
maßnahmen gegner über freie plätze im
lokalen im zentrum im kart ich wollte
nur kurz einen organisatorischen hinweis
an sie richten bezüglich der impfung
und zwar gibt es am ket noch freie
plätze heute für sich irgendjemand
impfen lassen will kann man das heute
tun
und hat dazu jede möglichkeit seine
eigene gesundheit und die gesundheit
anderer menschen zu schützen mit solch
einer durchsage kaum einer gerechnet
einzige reaktion auf die ansage ein teil
konzert